- I'm Rob Lowe.
- And I'm John Owen Lowe.
- And we're going to answer some questions
from inside this cookie jar.
(dramatic music)
- Let's pick one.
- Johnny, your oldest Instagram post
is a picture from an Elton John show.
Kinda looks like he's yelling at you
for taking the picture though.
(screaming)
What's something
in your life you wish you
had photographic evidence of?
- Good question.
When I beat you for the
first time in tennis
and you almost cried.
- I don't think that's true.
- That's why I need evidence.
- I'm now going to lift the head.
- Okay.
John Owen, sometimes you go by Johnny,
but sometimes you've gone by John.
This show is now called
Bro'in with John Owen.
What?
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Hi, my name is say your name,
welcome to Bro'in with John Owen.
Have you ever wondered how many Johns
can John Owen Lowe can shout
out in under 30 seconds?
Let's find out.
Ready, set, go.
John Stamos, Elton John, John Legend.
John Lennon.
John Wayne Gacy.
Ah, John.
- Jacob Jingleheimer Schmidt.
John Florence. He's a surfer.
John.
- Kennedy.
John Paul Gaultier,
that's a Jean, I think, dammit!
God!
(upbeat suspenseful music)
- Rob, you were one of the
stars of the 1983 classic
"The Outsiders," where
you played a character
named Soda Pop.
To officially end this age old debate,
should sugary carbonated drinks
be referred to as soda or pop?
Well, you know the answer to
that depends on where you live.
It's a geographical question.
Pop is a Midwestern, now I'm from Ohio,
we call them pop.
Soda is everywhere but the Midwest.
(horse neighing)
So the answer is depends
on where you live.
(ice clinking)
- Whatever.
- And now, once again,
for the ceremonial lifting of the head.
- Rob, you were a member
of the infamous Brat Pack back in the day.
Bratwurst is a type of German sausage.
How would you rate your
bratwurst grilling skills?
Das ist gut or are you ze worst?
- Well you know, I think
that it's very good.
You have the mustard and then
you course you have the kraut
and then you know, you put
it in some kind of a bread
and you feed it to a mini horse.
- It's good.
Get in there.
Go quick.
- Lowe's.
- That's us.
- This ain't your first rodeo
sharing the screen together.
In fact, you previously had a show called
"The Lowe Files" where
you investigated UFOs.
Among other things, okay, not just UFOs.
On a scale of comet bacteria
to aliens built the pyramids,
and I think they might have,
where do your beliefs land now?
Is the truth out there?
Well, I just returned from Egypt
to find these things out myself
and I was a big believer
that maybe the aliens built the pyramids.
But after having just been there,
I think that the pyramids
might just have been built by Egyptians.
- Okay.
- Boring.
- Yeah. It's all nonsense.
- All nonsense?
- Yeah. Well, I mean maybe aliens.
- But you were the resident cynic always.
- Yeah, that's the rational take.
- But what about the disclosure?
All the UAPs, as they call 'em.
- The what?
- He doesn't read the news.
I was supposed to remove the head.
- No. Okay. Yeah, whatever you'll be okay.
Ben? Is there a Ben?
I don't know who Ben is.
- This is really good.
- Let's try and figure out
- Let's try to get to the Ben.
- Who this Ben is.
- Is it Ben Affleck?
Is it Uncle Ben?
- If he's Ben Affleck,
that's pretty cool.
- Is it Uncle Ben?
- I know.
- Stove Top stuffing?
- There's a Ben on "Shadow and Bone."
- Ooh.
This whole Ben thing that's going on.
- I'm not liking where this is going.
- Me neither.
- Ben.
The point is, Ben, get
out of our interview.
- Yeah.
- This is about us.
- This is my interview for my show.
- It's our show.
(bleep) Ben.
- Rob, in your new show "Unstable,"
you play a character named Ellis Dragon.
If you rearrange the
letters in Ellis Dragon
you get Ireland slog.
The direct slog from Los Angeles
to Dublin takes 10 hours, shite.
How are you getting through that flight?
On a flight of that length,
it's almost the perfect amount of time
to watch all of season one of "Unstable."
- Okay, well that's enough of that.
Thank you so much for watching and...
- And check out "Unstable" season one.
Squeezed.
- Don't you know when it comes out?
- "Unstable" season one now
streaming only on Netflix.
- What day?
March 30th.
- I just says now streaming.
It doesn't say the date.